we're in the middle of summer right now
course and I came across this story
recently I want to share this with you
it turns out that a number of teens
getting jobs over summer vacation has
dropped dramatically people wonder
what's going on yeah what do you think
that is Annie do you think teams are
getting lazy or something well you know
that's what I thought at first but it's
actually because more teens are using
their summer to take college prep
classes which is good news they had a
chart in the article and I took a screen
grab of it Billy can you put that screen
grab up from my computer not see the
graph says that the overall length of
time that kids will at their purchased
I'm sorry Andy Andy Andy just wait a
minute okay your screen grab alright you
just put up your screen grab we can see
the other tabs you have open on your web
browser well wait what are you talking
abou League open go tie it on any
screenshot all right you have a tab open
for website teen milfs you have one for
cheap heroin and one for a site called
Conan stinks what the hell is going on
Andy how dare you Conan Billy click on
my teen milfs tab milks milfs stands for
Methodists inspiring love for service
it's a charity to help teens volunteer
in their community okay I'm really sorry
Andy it just looked creepy to me well it
wasn't creepy at all it was helpful okay
hey well what about this what about
cheap heroin I explained that one it is
a store that sells discount female
heroes costumes
cheap heroin costumes that you got cut
off in the tab I wanted to help
lower-income girls feel empowered they
were gonna be a surprise for comic-con
but not anymore sorry girls conan ruined
it okay all right so what about this
what about coat instincts well Conan the
Barbarian does stink
my preferred warrior is King Elric of
melon de Beaune okay Andy
that last one was stupid but I still I
still owe you an apology
okay your creepy-sounding browser tabs
weren't creepy at all now thank you
that's that's right so you won't mind if
we click on the LA Times tab that's
there
well what why would you it's just a la
Billy click on the LA Times ok here we
go
I think we have
yes why did you bring the bicycle seat
into your mug shot that's my only
question it's the wait is it in your mug
shot that's the way the Burbank PD does
it all right somebody I got a hold the
weapon here very good
you